well good afternoon everyone uh welcome
to university medical center i'm mason
van hollen the chief executive officer
and
today is an historic and exciting day uh
for umc
and our community and our first line
responders so uh
as of this morning was notified that the
vaccination the covenant vaccination
pfizer was
arrived to las vegas and gmc was
prepared and ready to receive the first
initial shipment of the vaccine
so after 10 long months and
very hard work by all of our frontline
workers
all our care and compassion and
understanding the state of nevada the
solution
is inside and being vaccinated and
rolled out to all of our employees
we've already vaccinated about 200
individuals today
a mix of individuals that are working
inside umc
inside our cova units treating patients
from doctors nurses respiratory
technicians
evs pharmacy and many others so
we're very excited again we really had
tears in our eyes as
the vaccine was arrived here at umc
today and we immediately
started rolling it out to our employees
who were very excited
and eager to receive the vaccine so
again the solutions here
it's been a long road and we're very
excited to be able to be
the first hospital to roll it out in the
entire state so we prepared
many many days and weeks for this and
again we will continue to vaccinate
throughout the the rest of the week and
fully vaccinate all of our employees in
the next seven days
we received around 1850 vials of
the pfizer covent vaccine um
it takes about 30 minutes to de-thaw the
viru
the vaccine but we're doing a systematic
approach to be able to roll that out
to make sure we're being very efficient
and effective and not having any waste
at all
but again we've uh done a few hundred
employees
inside and we will continue to vaccinate
vaccine
and immunize our employees throughout
the rest of the week so
with that i just want to say i
appreciate the partnership with the
state the health district our federal
delegation
and all the researchers and scientists
but most importantly those individuals
that volunteered to be in the trial for
the vaccine
it really is a life changer and i see
hope on the horizon and
things moving very quickly for our
community so with that i'm open any
questions you may have
um
so we have an entire process here at umc
it's very thorough well thought out
and follows all the cdc and health
district guidelines so
in fact i will uh let me
get here in my pocket here this is
actually the first vial
that was actually uh given today this is
empty
it's already been utilized but in this
vial we're able to get
five doses of the uh vaccine out to our
employees so it's 1.5 milliliters
so we break that down in 0.3 micrograms
and we're able to dispense this very
quickly
within about 15 minutes to five
employees so
again this is the first vial that's been
administered in the state of nevada
so just to break it down each file
correct so we will uh we'll break down
those vials and those doses
they come in 975
vials in a frozen block so we we do is
systematically break that block up
we dethaw them um takes about 30 minutes
but if we don't dethaun they can stay in
the freezer for up to six months but we
anticipate
uh thawing all the vaccines that we have
here and rolling that out in the next
seven
to eight days
yeah we have about 4 000 employees here
at umc
at umc alone but we also vaccin
vaccinate our
partners at unlv medicine on our
community doctor so
you can add another about 800 on that
number so we'll do close to 5000
over the next seven to eight days again
it's uh
front line workers initially those that
are actually treating patients
actively treating patients we have about
129 patients
in umc currently that were treating
actively for covid
and so a lot of that staff was here
early this morning
and then 21 days later they'll get the
second vaccination the booster
uh and then we're tracking that very
closely so
but again very thorough process that we
have inside
uh we we go through a lot of screening
questions making sure
people are immune compromised or
blood thinners or pregnant or
breastfeeding those type of things so
and then we'll actually administer the
vaccine we have them wait for 15 minutes
to make sure that there's no side
effects or reactions
we have not had any uh yet today i'm
very encouraged and the staff are back
at the bedside so it's going very
smoothly today and
i just want to say thank you to the umc
team to making it so smooth and
um really effortless they are doing a
great job and lots of excitement and
like i said
lots of tears this morning because there
is the solution is here
so we have once we thought we have five
days five days to
to administer the vaccine so time is is
critical and of the essence so we're
moving very quickly and uh
trying not to push up against that five
days but they're thawing uh defaulting
fast as we can and work the demand is
there so
uh we have no problems to meet in that
five day time frame and is it mandatory
for your staff
or is it or is it voluntary it is
voluntary highly encouraged um
we have a lot of interest so
but we're tracking every employee that's
had the vaccine initial and then the
second booster
and following them to make sure that
they come back and make sure that
they're fully
um protected and uh but again
not mandatory um not mandatory in the
state or the country yet but
we're probably gonna see greater than 90
acceptance rate
mary
so no so what we have mary today is uh
we got a call very early on
we're really expecting to roll this out
wednesday
uh but we got a call from the health
district and said
it's here uh i said we're ready and
let's get it rolling so
this all happened within a matter of
hours
it was transported from the health
district right around 11
10 today 11 10 a.m we started
vaccinating our first employer around 11
45
as you can see that that dethawing
process and then administering to our
first
frontline workers so so not anything
related to walgreens or cvs
this is solely healthcare workers at
this point tier one
are they um able to get the vaccine
while they're
in the hospital and if they are when
would they be able to get it back
yeah we're looking at all those patients
that may be compromised
vulnerable within that tier one as you
know nursing home patients
are the most vulnerable so we'll be
working very closely with the nursing
home
community and the health district to be
able to roll that out to make sure that
we're protecting the healthcare workers
in nursing homes
but also in patients in the nursing
homes and we'll also be looking at our
patients that are in umc as well
that'll we need to get through the
healthcare workers first obviously we're
in protective equipment
doing all the therapeutics and
treatments so we're doing really well at
the hospital and
again just very grateful for the time
the state gave us to be able to prepare
for this historic day uh it's here and
uh we're looking good we're very excited
so uh so yeah umc we have to keep this
in deep storage
so negative 71 73 degrees
we're able to receive a lot of the
vaccine so it'll be coming directly
to us after this first initial wave from
the health district
and uh again they'll be coming daily so
i don't anticipate uh
any run on sup the vaccine or being
short at all it's
it's moving very quickly and again very
appreciative to all those that
have been able to get it here in our
community have there been any lessons
in the near future in the process you
know i i like to say we've learned a ton
and
we're fixing a lot of things in the
hospital in the vaccine process but
you know we've been preparing for weeks
we have a great team here at umc
and uh great partnership with the health
district so
uh you know as we speak they're they're
shipping more to us so we're uh
um it's in the it's in the process but
you know we're working out some
some efficiency trying to get quicker
and faster on it but uh
everybody was excited and again a very
pleasant surprise this morning to be
able to start rolling out
the vaccination to our employees before
before noon
they were the first people in nevada
yes yep the first vaccine was given here
to a umc nurse that's uh treated many
many covet patients
in our icu uh it was a great story many
tears in our eyes and uh
and she went back right back to work so
uh it's not over
we still have a long road and uh just
you know really uh
stress to our community please continue
to do the things that
we've been asking you to do there's
light at the end of the tunnel
very appreciated that the governor kept
us in a pause and that we didn't roll
back any more restrictions
he was here this morning saw the process
uh was very pleased and um
but uh yeah that's uh that the first
first uh
person in nevada was vaccinated and was
an employee uh umc a nurse in the icu
did the governor also receive a vaccine
no no he is uh
he is waiting just like i am and we're
going to let everybody
get going first we are we will be the
last and uh he was just a very
appreciative the hard work of the
employees here at umc
uh as you know he's this has been his
hospital for many many years
he knows us well and just wanted to come
out and thank the staff and those that
were given the vaccine in the health
district
you know i think we're gonna it's gonna
take a little while to see the effects
uh you know
i think the key is protecting our front
line healthcare workers
so they have a little bit more peace of
mind that the the vaccine
is is uh taking effect and and we're
gonna be tracking that very closely with
side effects and
how they're doing the hospital is about
88 full
um about 32 percent of our patients are
coveted
uh but umc we do a lot of testing on
every patient that comes through so
we're unique
so about a third of those patients we're
detecting that are asymptomatic they're
here for other reasons
so we're able to very quickly provide
precautions
do the ppe treatments and therapeutics
but we're about 88
of our capacity right now but we're
really doing well again i'm appreciative
of the governor
holding the line where we're at we think
it's effective it definitely could be a
lot worse if
we weren't in the situation but um again
hope is on the way and the vaccine will
take
a few weeks and especially as we get it
out to the general community
yeah staffing's tight you know uh we're
we're uh we continue to work hard um
lots of lots of extra shifts and lots of
uh
overtime being work but the staff the
morale is very high
and again this is just a boost of the
arm for the morale as well
so the question is if if are there
staffers that are a little hesitant to
get the shot i think
you know seeing the folks come through
the line today and seeing some of our
leaders and nurse managers and
folks that are out there on the front
lines i think we're going to have a very
good acceptance rate mary but we will
have those that
kind of wait and see and see how it goes
just like with the flu vaccine every
year
you know we still have portions of our
population in our community that just
will you know forego the flu vaccine so
i suspect that will be the same here
uh in nevada but uh i think many are
very eager to get this and i know my
phone is
constantly blowing up on when it's going
to be rolled out to the community and i
think
rolling out to the general public will
probably be more
uh late january time frame early
february
hopefully sooner but no later than march